[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
is Chris Haynes there ready to join us
the popular reporter sideline reporter
NBA on TNT an Insider for Bleacher
Reports sat down with Kevin Durant
recently Chris good to see you again
explain to me how you reach out you get
Kevin Durant to sit down for an
interview how long you had you been
working on that
I text well first of all thanks for
having me DP
um I text KD probably about two or three
days before
um he was to come to Sacramento where
I'm based where I have a home out out
there in Sacramento and uh let them know
I wanted to talk to him I wanted to you
know try to get him after the game or
before the game
and a lot of times you know KD's often
busy sometimes he sees the text and
that's what I want to do I want to put
it on his radar so I did that he never
got a response so I'm like okay I'm
pretty sure he saw it but I'll try to
get with him at the game so I arrived at
the arena and Mark Spears my brother at
anscape he was there and we both wanted
to chat with KD so we bumped into KD
before he was to take the court for his
pregame
um work out so we talked to them chopped
it up man we haven't seen KD in probably
about a year and so we told him like
look we would like to have some time
with you and he was like no problem no
problem I got you Brothers I'll get you
after the game so this this was actually
after the game and it wasn't a time when
in which he um excuse me it wasn't a
time in which he felt like venting
because of a loss
um because you know he was frustrated
this was already set okay so I got with
him after the game we spoke for about 15
minutes anything off limits
no I think if you I think you saw the
story
what jumped out at you Chris from what
Durant had to say
well I think what jumped out I think he
knew the the line of questioning that I
was going to come forth with uh what
jumped out to me was that for whatever
reason he was just prepared
to answer those questions we never
really knew why he requested the
training
um you know he goes into details about
how he was going to Steve Nash and tell
him look I don't think we're prepared
properly properly we're not doing enough
practice we're not doing enough shell
drills uh we're not spending enough time
on defense and you know KD like one
thing about covering this guy for
I don't know half a decade longer than
that on a day-to-day basis that I know
that he's one of the most tireless
workers we have in the Superstar class
in the NBA and so he really does value
uh what it takes to compete at a
championship level he he values the
preparation and so for him saying that
speaks volumes and I know there is a
quote
out there that he said where he mentions
his teammates about you know he talked
about the Starting Fire that they
brought out there in Sacramento and
basically what he was saying is that you
know there's all this there's all this
scrutiny on a team that isn't whole you
know when he and that's why he would
mentioned those names it's like what are
you expecting from that group he wasn't
mentioning it as a disrespect he's
basically saying that these are guys
that are were not supposed to be
starting five caliber guys as they were
supposed to be complimentary players and
we're doing the best that we can to
maximize that group and in that quote
right after that quote he says I'm
enjoying playing basketball with them
I'm enjoying getting getting to see the
defenses that teams are throwing against
me and I'm trying to figure it out
navigate it and work my guys into it and
he's saying he's having probably one of
the most fun times of his career so that
part gets left out in him naming and on
that starting five but you know I I was
just you know I really was I got to be
honest I was just taken back by how
um how upfront he was willing to go that
night
how much blame does he take for what has
happened there
I mean he he definitely has to show to
some of the blame I mean but does he I
mean I he helped build this and then
wanted to leave
and and that's what I said look you want
to be a leader a leader would stay and
say how do we fix this not I want to I
want to check out
well I I don't I don't I don't know if I
buy that DP because we've we've always
had Superstars that requested trades and
so you know it does come a point to
where what you sign up for doesn't
materialize but he wanted Steve Nash I
mean they wanted DeAndre Jordan for
God's sakes you got Kyrie you I mean he
he helped build this not every superstar
gets to build a team pick your coach
and and KD did
he he did but again
it didn't work out
um Steve Nash was obviously that
somebody who didn't have experience as a
head coach before it just didn't pan out
and I think you have to remember Steve
Nash was with the Golden State Warriors
on a part-time basis and you know that's
when I was in the Bay area so I saw the
relationship that bonded uh and was
forced between those two and so I think
maybe KD felt like you know Steve Nash
being in the Warriors infrastructure
seeing how they get down on a
preparation basis I I think he felt like
you know Steve Nash would Implement some
of those same things there in Brooklyn
and and it didn't work out
um you know obviously you got the James
Harden situation that that went South he
was in for a hot minute and out the Ben
Simmons hasn't worked out Kyrie Irving
look yes we there were signs and I you
know I actually you know I remember
um when Kevin Durant was a free agent I
went to his he had a house and rent a
house in the Beverly Hills
um that summer and I went over there to
do a story on them and you know this was
I think this was right before it might
have been right after he chose
um Ness and I I asked him I'm like
what's your comfort level with Kyrie at
that point because at the time we saw
what happened with Cleveland and we saw
what happened to Boston and I believe at
that time he told me that you know we
just don't understand Kyrie you know
he's a Hooper he's just like me he's
somebody who just wants to play
basketball so I the impression I got
they felt like Kyrie was misunderstood
so definitely you have to
uh put some onus on Kevin Durant because
he did have a lot of say so but
ultimately
he doesn't make the final call the final
calls are from the head coach and for
management and it's just things that he
felt that he signed up for did
ultimately materialize and that's what
led him to request the trade over the
summer
talking to Chris Haynes NBA on TNT
sideline reporter Insider for Bleacher
Report what is the likelihood that Kyrie
Irving is not with this team
later on maybe uh in the next couple of
months do you think Kyrie's here for
this entire season
I do okay I do
um tradable and that's why he's gonna be
there
hey TP that's why you're good at what
you do that's why that's why you're the
best man uh let me let me answer that
question no so he will sorcer told me he
will he's expected to return this Sunday
against the Memphis Grizzlies that would
be the Brooklyn Nets first home game
after this road trip
with that being said you know look it I
can't I can't sit here and lie to you
and say that there's much there's much
value in training for Kyrie I I haven't
I'm on the phones with a lot of teams
his name is not really coming up you
know even for the Los Angeles Lakers who
he was tied to for much much of the off
season uh that's just not something I'm
hearing right now
um to answer your question be peace but
if you're talking about Beyond this
season do I see Kyrie with the Nets
that's really hard to see I I can't
imagine a scenario where where he would
be a member of the Nets by next season
I'll leave you with this we brought this
up uh yesterday or the day before is
Kyrie Irving
a Hall of Famer
I think
if his season were to end now
I'm not saying he's not deserving but I
think if if his career were to end now
I don't think he would get the voting to
get in he's still young enough I believe
he's 30.
so he's still young enough to
get six or seven more dominant years
under his belt and try to get behind
just all this drama we've seen over the
last five years there's still time
enough to solidify that spot but I think
if it were to his career were to end
right now I don't think he would have
the support are you putting in a
requests to interview Kyrie
uh Kyrie though I'm available
is Kyrie available that's what I want to
know well you know
that's a different question right there
but uh you know I think at some point
you know there's there's a few
requirements or maybe one requirement
left
um before he's able to play Sunday I do
believe he will have to speak to members
of the media before he plays Sunday
games so that's something to look out
for uh before I let you go uh Marvin is
controlling the playlist today with the
cookout and uh Marvin uh do you want to
tell well Chris do you have a playlist
for a cookout
for a cookout so when I think of a
cookout DP I'm thinking about throwing
something on that Grill throwing the
slab of ribs on the grill no music
rocking out music Marvin gives it give
Chris I'm gonna go I'm gonna hold on I'm
gonna have Marvin give you his playlist
today that we're playing okay all right
all right so we got uh Frankie Beverly
and Maze Before I Let Go
uh got to give it up Marvin Gaye
Lakeside Fantastic Voyage
okay uh
and then oh I had Shalimar A Night to
Remember
in uh Parliament flashlight
okay what I was about to say before you
you mentioned those those songs I was
gonna go 70s anytime you having a
cookout a barbecue 70s music gets the
job done it gets everybody in the mood
and most of those songs he mentioned
were the 70s if not all of them so
that's that's how I would rock out all
right just want to make sure because uh
when I go to Marvin's cookout next
summer I just want to make sure that I'm
ready when I get there
okay DP Marvin I would say this Marvin
you got to play The Cupid Shuffle and
get DPN on the dance oh boy that's
something you got You Gotta Throw Cupid
Shuffle in there well I was going to say
Chris if he knew the words to Frankie
Beverly and Maze Before I Let Go
somebody gonna fix him a plate
Chris have you ever been to the Cozy in
Indianapolis
I never have no okay
I went in there and realized that uh I
was in the minority when I went in there
but I I I I said you know what I'm just
gonna I'm gonna go in and get a beer
next thing I know they did the um like
the Soul Train where they line up on
both sides and then you gotta dance down
the middle of it and I thought you know
what let's go and I was with her I was
with a producer of mine Charlie Monahan
I said Charlie let's go and I I remember
acting like I was on a horse and
spanking my backside as I'm heading down
the yeah and I'm like all right we're
good and everybody was like all right
you're all right we're good with you at
DP it only lasts for a few seconds I
know in your mind it may feel like an
eternity going down that line it's it's
over in a few seconds and you're
accepted so so wrong with the DP yeah
this was when Indiana was in the NBA
finals and I thought all right let's go
get a beer I just done I just hung out
with Mark Jackson Reggie Miller we
walked over there and I walked in it's
one of those like Animal House
Otis my man and I you know you walk in
and everybody turned around I'm like
I'm walking to the bar I'm gonna go I'm
gonna get a beer and I I needed Stuart
Scott there I think with me
oh that would have been awesome a DP man
you always invited
anytime uh congrats on the interview
there Chris always great to talk to you
DP take care bro that's Chris Haynes
works for uh Bleacher Report also TNT
the NBA on TNT